[Música]
llena del vacío entre el cielo y la
tierra
quitan nuestras aceras nuestros parques
nuestros bosques su longevidad su
aspecto y lo que han vivido no tienen
comparación son árboles extraordinarios
el uso en el departamento de sol en el
norte de francia
estos dos tilos centenarios se unieron y
entrelazaron con el paso del tiempo para
formar uno solo incluso han marcado la
historia de la comuna desde hace 300
años determinan el futuro de los recién
casados
esta leyenda o más bien esta tradición
consistía en que el día de una boda se
organizaba una pequeña carrera entre los
recién casados la pareja salía de la
iglesia después del servicio llegaba
aquí y tras la señal tenían que correr
hacia este árbol y como decía la
tradición el primero en pasar el maestro
será o sea que la primera persona que
pasaba entre los troncos era la que
llevaba los pantalones en el hogar no
sabemos si el marido dejaba ganar a su
esposa si era galante o si le hacía
tropezar antes del final de la carrera
estos impresionantes árboles despiertan
la imaginación y también tranquilizan la
mente
lugones mons lleva años practicando
terapia del bosque el arte de
comunicarse con las plantas para ello
nada mejor que un gran roble
no
traten de sentir lo que sucede bajo sus
pies
para llegar hasta el árbol los
participantes empiezan a ciegas
caminando hacia los
un poco la esencia se mantengan los ojos
cerrados y cuando estén listos abran los
sugerencias
[Música]
van a sentir la vida al interior del
horno
ya desde lejos a 15 ó 20 metros podría
sentir un cosquilleo en las manos lo que
quiere decir que la energía está ahí si
cosquilleo y cuando más lo hace uno más
se siente con el tiempo las primeras
veces uno se dice esto es raro y luego
se convierte en algo natural
ahora vamos a tener todos nuestros
nervios conectados al árbol relaje en
los hombros también podemos tomar
algunas respiraciones profundas
y dijo
que a veces un árbol puede estar torcido
y alguien le dice a uno este árbol
encaja conmigo porque así es como me
siento así que habrá una especie de
metáfora de conexión y la persona podrá
sanar gracias a desear voltor ciento
torcidos o torturados los árboles siguen
viviendo como esta software a japónica y
yo increíble tamaño despierta asombro y
curiosidad se encuentra en cena y marc
en región parisina en medio de un
establecimiento para la integración
social de jóvenes que abandonaron sus
estudios los jóvenes dibujan el árbol
regularmente
puedes ver que hay toda una zona en la
parte de arriba donde no se ven las
ramas es todo verde cierto
ve hasta allá o sea que en tu dibujo
puedes poner ramas solo hasta acá pero
no hasta arriba
también hay un poco de verde y un poco
de verde es otro color o no no vale
entonces intenta mezclar los colores
para entender esta silueta tan
particular tenemos que hacer un rápido
viaje en el tiempo en 1930 a sus 25
metros de altura
el árbol cayó debido a una tormenta
podría haber muerto pero otras ramas
aparecieron para formar un nuevo tronco
desde entonces está protegido para
alegría de los estudiantes que ven en
este árbol el símbolo de su propia
reconstrucción
[Música]
no sé qué
foto ahí que tuve sabemos que le cayó un
rayo que se cayó que trataron de cortar
lo que a pesar de todo fue capaz de
renacer de sus cenizas y bueno eso nos
da fuerzas para renacer de las nuestras
porque llegamos acá pensando que
habíamos fracasado y esta institución
nos ha dado una forma de avanzar en la
vida de encontrar otro camino
desde que abro las cortinas de mi
habitación es lo primero que veo es algo
que uno no puede pasar por alto sin
notarlo está ahí puedo y significa mucho
para nosotros es una verdadera fuente de
inspiración
cada vez hay más conciencia en abril de
2019 en francia se emitió una
declaración de los derechos del árbol
esta proclama que los árboles son seres
vivos toda una revolución cultural
tal vez en un futuro los árboles dejen
de ser considerados
exclusivamente como materiales y más
como transmisores de historia